[Music]
Oh
the first film was like an awakening
this film becomes more intricate more
suspenseful new trait Kristen knows that
he needs Allah in his life I want you
back I had no idea what this was gonna
become this time no laws no punishments
and no more secrets in dark what's so
much happening we've bought these new
characters and we see them develop good
morning mr. Hanna
uh-huh please it's Jack Jack Hyde he
comes across as a great ideal boss and
then it kind of quickly devolves from
there Anna becomes rattled by Christians
past is about the psychological threat
and an Christian coming apart and a
actual physical threat that's
threatening their lives I love that
thriller aspect and the element of
danger gets darker and darker
you know that girl Kristen
do you think you're the first woman
she's tried to save him ultimately it's
an epic love story one of them has very
dark desires and another has to find
that within herself because they love
each other so deeply
there's a lot of sexiness on the camera
that's not just in the bedroom it's a
psychological thriller your boyfriend
has a reputation that's huge of us heavy
if something were to happen to you I
could never forgive myself even if you
haven't seen the first movie it's still
very satisfying
do you want to be count I have respect
we have lots of fans and can't wait to
see what Christian and Anna get up to
you next
and we actually deliver tell me what you
have that I don't
so you come back
[Music]
you